what could a fake guru Friday on a
Saturday today we've got an exciting one
for you guys that I've saved for fake
guru 10 because it's oh this is juicy
got a juicy one for you guys so let's
just we're just gonna unravel this
slowly okay
I'm not even tell you who our fake guru
is yet all I'm gonna show you is that
this this first cave on who is a one of
those financial gurus you know you've
seen them we've done them all on this
show okay you go to the site because
you've got the one call closer
methodology stop selling start closing
and why should you hire cave oh well
kayvon is the guy he's done a lot look
at it and look at him right there doing
business look at him right there
speaking at Harvard the Harvard Business
Club incredible incredible except not
everything is how it seems let's go back
to let's let's go to his little speech
which is online
kayvon featured speaker featured speaker
for business expert forum at Harvard
faculty club now that sounds pretty
professional
[Music]
about to get juicy
[Music]
our featured speaker is a two-time
collegiate male athlete of the year
please welcome the one and only
kayvon stop what does this look like
this
what impression would this give you
Kalin is speaking in Harvard oh great
Harvard invited him to speak pretty
pristine if they don't invite a lot of
people he's up there with the likes of
Bill Gates right with with the likes of
Jeff Bezos okay Bezos okay that's what
it's like pays off I can still remember
it I'm 19 years old driving in a
third-world country with my parents
hands are grabbing me I'm ripped from
the car tossed into a van speeding off
in the opposite direction when I finally
came to I found myself in a dark alley
if you've been living as a kidnap victim
here telling you and the harbor's crest
is here telling you to believe in
yourself so you can discover your truth
look at the fear-driven parts of your
life and realize making a move it won't
end it it will begin it let me tell you
guys a little secret that wasn't Harvard
that wasn't thought that wasn't the
Harvard School of Business
kayvon was not invited by Harvard kayvon
is not affiliated with Harvard that was
a speech all set up by the fake guru of
fake gurus who sets up speeches that
appear as though they're hosted by very
prestigious places such as West Point
such as Harvard such as Nasdaq such as
Coca Cola when in reality they have no
affiliation with these people at all but
the fate you were a fake gurus gets his
the fake gurus to pay him money to go
speak there and in fact this crowd that
you see is not a real crowd at all they
didn't come to see Kavon speak actually
most of these people are going to give
their speeches later and they'll be
recorded and then they can go and put
their thing on and Kavon will be in the
audience at that point clapping and
pretending to care because none of this
is real this is this is an elaborate
tool
to create what Clint Arthur the
organizer of this the fake guru of fake
gurus cause marketing material marketing
material for you to believe that these
people have something that you don't
have to believe that these people have
spoken it the likes of Harvard at the
likes of West Point at the lights of
Nasdaq at the likes of coca-cola when in
reality they haven't okay so now it's
time to introduce you to Clint Arthur
Clint Arthur is this guy right here he
is a former taxi driver who decided that
he he wanted to teach people how to be
celebrities and cleaner Arthur has a
very basic approach this he's kind of
like that guy have you ever seen people
who all they do is take pictures next to
famous people and they think that
proximity to success is success like
they think just because you take a
picture with Snoop Dogg you're gonna be
Snoop Dogg okay that's this guy Clint
Arthur a personal branding expert
Wharton School of Business graduate etc
cutter and he's got all these pictures
of him with these famous people I'm not
sure any of them know him he might have
just photo point
photobomb it but he's got a lot of
testimonials here but his simple premise
is that he will get you on he hacks your
way onto these like local TV spots and
he'll make you get you marketing
materials such as you speaking in
Harvard etc now if you think wow that
sounds really sketchy and a little
scummy
well you I think you're right which is
why it's surprising that the Wall Street
Journal says the guy who gets financial
advisor speaking engagements at Harvard
that surprised you said but when you
actually go to it the first sentence of
the entire article is more than a dozen
financial advisors claim to give given
speeches of Harvard Business School and
US Military Academy at West Point but
they weren't invited to speak by those
leading universities this article is
like a hit piece on Glenn Arthur and
Glenn Arthur is the kind of guy who will
take your hit piece and put it in the
testimonial section our website because
when you go there he's got it as the
first
it's his first testimony
is the guy who gets financial advisor
today if you actually click on the
article it's like skate it's a scathing
review of this guy and he puts it on the
first testimonial is that anyway that's
the kind of guy we're dealing with
that's the kind of guy that clean Arthur
is and this boldness this brashness has
led him to do things like faking the
Harvard logo like you see this right
here this is from the Harvard you know
business thing it's not real that this
is not the real Harvard logo and it's
designed to look like the Harvard logo
but not exact so look for liability
reasons it cannot be the Harvard logo
the real Harvard logo is this it says
Veritas well Clint Arthur's Harvard logo
says Veritas in negociate sounds a bit
like truth is negotiable but actually it
means truth in business which is sort of
more ironic because of course there's no
truth here at all it's it's you're
faking you're literally faking a an
invitation at leading universities using
their name just to push yourself to the
top in this really scummy way but
probably what I hate the most from Clint
is this he just he's just shameless
he's so look this is him talking to his
his people the people who pay him
thousands tens of thousands of dollars
to go ahead and get these speeches at
Harvard and and these people by the way
that we'll get into who does this more
they're in full awareness that this is
not real he tells him right up front
this isn't real and they go through with
anyway so I I don't know I don't know if
I'm more shocked that someone does this
or that people actually buy this from
and they feel okay about this look this
is what this is what Clint Arthur dares
to say about getting the most from
Harvard you have to post accurately and
not misrepresent what this is I have
seen people posting hey I'm really
excited I'm gonna be speaking at Harvard
well that's not really true you're not
speaking at Harvard you're speaking at
the Harvard Club of Boston and that's
not quite the same is it as saying
no it's not quite the same Clinton but
are you surprised that people are saying
this why do you think they're joining
your thing meaning that you're speaking
at Harvard so I would really encourage
you to always be truthful in your
marketing oh my god did the guy the guy
who sells fake speeches the Harvard is
saying always be truthful in your
marketing what oh this guy for real
I look did I not tell you that this
smash like right now look did I if I did
if I came true if I'm coming through my
promise that this is an unbelievable
story smash like right now okay smash it
then subscribe to this channel and then
listen to Clinton Arthur go on and take
the high ground the moral high ground on
why you should be truthful at marketing
and never ever lie never say that you're
doing something that you're not doing
when we were doing our events sponsored
by the Entrepreneurship Club of Harvard
Business School we had many financial
advisors many financial advisors who
posted on their websites here's my video
speaking at Harvard Business School
that's not true
why would they do that
why would they do that click why this
whole reason they paid for your service
Clint come on you can't be this dumb
clip oh okay
so sorry sorry so he goes on and of
course eventually Harvard does catch on
to this Harvard does find out what this
guy's didn't like look we're not gonna
let you rent a room if you're gonna be
doing this he no longer does it at
Harvard I believe West Point has
canceled him but does that stop Clint
comment below comment below whether you
think that stops Clint right now no no
it doesn't stop Clint Clint moves on and
find someone else to you know to abuse
their name when did Nasdaq is he really
speaking for Nasdaq did Nasdaq invite
him no no but if you pay several
thousands of dollars you can speak at a
million dollar business accelerator now
don't say you spoke for Nasdaq okay guys
that would be lying and we don't want to
do that we just want to tell the truth
what but what's upset a little upsetting
for me is that he's he's always claiming
that his his speakers are actually
getting results from this what happened
for you leading up to the Nasdaq speech
that you did in April it was amazing
you know I actually took and started
using in my newsletters my company and
stuff and I started talking about me
going to Nasdaq to my clients and
prospects and stuff and I actually got
to meetings to go you know talk to
clients and and it was directly from
saying I was gonna talk in a sec so
before I even spoke at Nasdaq and I was
telling you this the pre-party and in
New York about this and we ended up wet
and landing those clients there were
$300,000 worth $300,000 of revenue for
Fanta unfortunately this stuff that we
can laugh at that we could think is so
funny it alternate leads to people
getting misled about what these people
are and it leads it does lead to fake
fame and people end up losing money I
mean presumably these people wouldn't
have done business with this guy if they
had known he
wasn't really at Nasdaq but because it
looked like it the guy got the business
that he was looking for and no one seems
to be talking about like that's kind of
a problem so other people that that more
prominence people that he's dealt with
so far we're talking about just like
people you might not have heard of
someone you might have heard of that's
done this with with all Clint is Jason
bond from Jason bond picks you probably
do no unfortunately he's taken his he's
taken his video off the web because I
think he realized it doesn't look too
good for him to be faking a speech at
Harvard but this guy is pretty
successful on YouTube I mean I've gotten
a lot of comments about like you know
reviewing him I'm not gonna review him
specifically but basically if someone
fakes a speech at Harvard I think you
can learn everything you need to know
from that person but look even though
it's a little bit depressing that people
do achieve some success by using these
these really scummy methods here's the
good news and I want to end it on a high
note okay let's figure routing so I want
to reflect a bit about what I've learned
from watching all these fake gurus you
could only fake it for so long
you can only pretend to be successful
for so long it does end up catching up
with you Clint Arthur it's catching up
with him he's had pieces done on him
he's lit more more and more limited in
the places he can they essentially do
these weird fake speeches that are faked
events at where it looks like they're
doing it for somebody but they're
actually a separate organization
entirely just using the name but he's
less and less able to do that and that's
a good thing and that's something we
have to remember going forward is these
guys even though they do sometimes make
a lot of money and they make it off the
backs of people who probably can't
afford it or misled by the offering it
does end up catching up and so that's
the good thing people like Jason Bohn
are haunted by the fact they they did
this and all these people you saw today
that are doing these fake speeches now
you know now you know who
they are what type of things they choose
to associate themselves like so with all
that said I want to talk to you guys
about something a little close to my
heart and that's microphone quality okay
so listen up to me good
listen up to me good right now okay
listen up
I've heard some nonsense being talked
some nonsense being talked in this in
this closed community we have together
right now and I just want to say don't
y'all ever make fun of my microphone
quality again okay
if you ever do that one more time thank
you is over thank you fake guru is over
so with that out of the way I just I
just gotta say this
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you to everyone who invited me to
speak at this prestigious university
okay now when I was a young boy sorry
it's every time I think about it when I
was invited to the business club the
school of Harvard not affiliated with
Harvard it choked me up because I
thought thought back to when I was a boy
and I knew at that moment that I was
gonna do something great don't ever ever
let dreams be dreams okay
you got to go out there and even if you
have to fake it till you make it you
gotta seize that train you gotta save it
and only then when you tell the truth
will you be free Thank You Harvard thank
you
I'm very honored thank you for inviting
me here I can't believe I can't believe
it I mean only only ten grants
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]